the greatest
movie I have ever seen hi doggy you're
my favorite customer someone made a game
about the the greatest movie of all time
I like to call it the greatest game of
all time it's I'm talking of course
about the room tribute hi doggy you're
my favorite customer all you need to
know is I love that movie more than I
love my CH which I don't have which I
mean I'm not capable to love it's what
I'm trying to say here uh I did not hit
her it's not true it's [__] I did
not hit her I did not oh hi Mark there's
going to be a ton of references so uh
just you're not going to get any of
it oh I've been waiting so long to play
this game I'm so
excited the music is
beautiful that's Tommy why is he a
statue what is he
doing what a
be I can't do Tomy what a beautiful day
I love his face whoa was that an earthqu
Le hey it's Greg holy crap Johnny did
you feel that oh hi Mark yes I
did this is very bad the bridge just
collapsed right behind
me are you okay
Mark yeah Johnny just very shaken up oh
my God it's Granny hello boys are you
all right oh hi clet yes we are fine is
Lisa
okay yes Lisa is fine but a bit shaken
up I better get home and uncomfortable
with
her now Johnny as my future son-in-law I
expect you to provide for Lisa oh yeah
she always refers to him as future
son-in-law or future wife or whatever
doesn't matter why am I I Lisa has been
eyeing up a red dress at the dress
shop wait is this
is this the prequel to the room now
would you be per now would be the
perfect time to give her a gift okay
clet whatever you say love is blun I'm
very I'm very busy so I got to run see
you guys
later Greg is always very busy and it's
never explained why and what he does
that he's so busy I'm eating shley for
coffee so I need to run as well need a
red sure great thought he was busy but I
guess guess he will so busy after all
look at Tommy he's so beautiful I love
him so much I better get
moving all right where do we go okay
where do we go then I haven't played a
point and click game in so
long okay let's go here oh my God the
bridge what is Spider-Man when you need
him where do I go how can you buy a
dress when love is
blun hey all right let's let's go
here
yes the buck oh my God hi doggy you're
my favorite customer hi
Johnny hi Johnny sorry your tuxedo isn't
ready yet I was actually thinking I
might buy a dress for my
Lisa that Lisa is one lucky
girl it's perfect this game is perfect
hi
doggy how are you
[Music]
doggy it's not even funny I'm just okay
let's pick up our red dress that one yes
holy [__] Tommy is Rich Johnny whatever
his name thank you you're my favorite
customer all right we got the dress
let's keep
[Music]
going hey we're at the house they
weren't allowed to film here I remember
they just took someone's random guy's
house it's
beautiful that's how you shoot in LA or
San Francisco oh hi
Johnny it says it there just so he
wouldn't remember the forget the lines
to the roof oh my God I can't wait to go
to the roof oh my God it's Lisa she
looks so beautiful let's give her the
red dress there we
go oh my god wow you look so sexy
Lisa isn't it fabulous oh my God I will
do anything for my
girl oh hey guys yeah
Daddy oh hi
Danny wow look at
you it's from
Johnny oh I'm sorry I realized this it's
not making any sense at all if you
haven't if you haven't seen the
movie or at least my other video how
much was it
Danny don't ask a question like that
nice to see you Denny I'm going to take
a
nap can I go upstairs
[Music]
too Danny I think I'm going to join
him join Lisa for nap time great I can't
wait are the spoons here there's the
spoon thank God
spoon I don't have any calls to make oh
yes I forgot about the tape recorder he
records all these [__]
tapes it's it's the most MacGyver move
of in the whole movie I got to say maybe
actually I don't know all right let's go
upstairs
whoa oh it's the
music
[Music]
yes oh it's beautiful I tear up every
time I hear it it's
amazing whoa whoa Johnny Johnny Johnny
it's possessed by
Satan it is
explain without you I totally know
the oh he looks
good Tommy wio always wear two belts as
well I wonder if there's a two belt
option I wouldn't do for you you are my
love my dream come
true this should be the national anthem
of this channel way of a
bullet I will run through the forest of
flame I hot
smooooch Denny do you have something
else to do I just like to watch you
guys oh Denny Denny boy
I get it you guys want to be alone
that's the
idea how old is Danny supposed to be I
never understood that bye love birds bye
Denny I love how they made Denny's
forehead [__]
humongous oh my God oh my God the
[Laughter]
peex I better get to work but where is
work
what is his job I don't know his
[Music]
job I don't
know Bank oh he works at the bank of
course of course my
bad great news Johnny we put your ideas
to work and the bank is making lots of
[Music]
money they're not going to give him a
promotion though that is great I get my
promotion sorry Johnny not yet but I'm
saving you lots of
money just a few more weeks Johnny
you're a favorite
[Music]
employe oh this is beautiful amazing
granny so did you get your promotion are
you making more money yet sorry clet no
they say a few more weeks if you're
going to be my son-in-law my future
son-in-law I mean my sonla you will need
to buy a house I know clent well don't
go home empty headed at least get leav
us some flowers before you break the
news I always wonder this game fills out
all the gaps from the movie it really
does and such a such a wonderful way and
the Granny's face is so so
beautiful I feel bad for granny there's
there's a story that she had to go to
the hospital while shooting the scene
because they wouldn't get air
conditioning in in the
house uh I don't know hey it's a flower
shop what the [__] is it going to be the
same lady yes yes it
is oh man a dozen red roses please can I
have oh can I have a dozen red Ros
please oh hi Johnny I didn't know it was
you here here you go that's me how much
is
it that it'll be $15 $18 here you go
keep the change you're my favorite
customer thanks a lot bye oh hi
[Music]
doggy all right we got a dozen red roses
let's go to Lisa and break the news that
the computer and she will tell us that
the computer business is very
competitive oh hi hi
Donnie there you go a dozen red
roses these are for
you thanks thanks honey they're
beautiful hi
babe is that for
you thanks honey they're beautiful you
didn't get it did you you didn't get it
did you but son of a [__] told me that
I would get it within three months that
son of a [__] told me that I would get
in a few month I saved them bundles they
crazy I don't think I will ever get it
Johnny that poor
soul I feel for it my heart bleeds for
you
John they betray me they didn't keep
their promise they trick me and I don't
care anymore they betrayed me they
didn't keep their promise they tricked
me and I don't care anymore did you tell
them how much you saved them of course
what do you think they already put my
ideas into practice and in the
morning I will run through the forest
the Flames I love how it comes in there
the bank saves
money and and they're using me and I'm
their
fool this game has all the best lines I
still love you no you don't Lisa you're
lying son of a [__] why would you lie
about that at least you have friends I
didn't get any calls today because the
computer business is very
competitive the computer business is too
competitive do you want me to order a
pizza you already ordered me a pizza
didn't you whatever I don't care
Lisa perfect girl you know whenever I
asked Maria to order me a pizza and she
says no and I said I order already
ordered you Pizza she doesn't even care
anymore you think about
everything well she didn't think about
the computer business being too
competitive did she you need a drink
what's the matter you're all right it's
just a lovey promotion you know what you
need you need a
drink
don't drink you know
that Lisa is so beautiful the Sprites
the Sprites of Lisa is really turning me
on oh my God I
forgot I have Tommy weo
here how can I forget I'm so stupid I
bought it just for the God damn it
Tommy what do you think about the game
you must be crazy I can't drink this if
you love me you'll drink this if you
love I'm sorry I need to stop you're
right it tastes
[Music]
good I know I'm right don't worry about
those [__] you're a good man drink
and let's have some
fun we have to sample this from the
movie The Sound uh the sound when he
drops the glass it's a it's beautiful it
sounds so real it feels like I'm in the
[Music]
room I'm tired I'm tired I'm wasted I
love you
darling come on make love to
me you you [__] lazy son of a
[__] come on you onlye me one I love
you Lisa I love you John where did it go
wrong where did it go wrong I don't
understand oh my God I can't don't open
your eyes like that again it's Terri oh
my God okay it's Thursday now here we go
let's go
inside just a few more weeks Johnny
that's it go home for [__] sake God
damn it you have a rough life Johnny I
gotta say it's got to be tough when when
the bank takes your ideas into practice
and they make money and I gotta say
though to be fair like Johnny's real
backstory of moving to San Francisco
it's pretty it's pretty inspiring all
right so I I I I admire you you're my
here all right do you hear that it
sounds like Denny oh no Danny oh no the
rooftop no Danny what have you done
no Danny's
please
daddy where's my [__] money daddy
where's my
money yes
what Chris R hell yeah what is
happening what yes uh what do I do throw
a
bottle oh of course he throws a water
bottle and they always throw football
come on throw the football
please
ah we got to do some damage on CH all oh
[__] it's shooting Johnny Johnny's
Avatar is beautiful all right T CH chip
chip chip chip yes ch ch ch chip
chip I'm such a [__] nerd I don't
give a [__]
glamour hell
yeah [__] Johnny is not doing too well I
got to say all right we got get this
bottle throw
going yes golden
bottle hell yeah now Mark throw that
football hell yeah take that [__] Chris
R we're going to have
to chip chip chip chip chip chip yeah
keep taunting
him
[__]
don't die
[Music]
Johnny yes got Chris
AR what's going on here somebody help
let's take him to the prison no the
police oh they are actually going to do
it I always wonder how they're so
fast yeah you're going to the police
you're going you're going for a very
long time boy you're going away for a
where is the
[Music]
police what the actual
[__] oh it's the coffee
shop yes here's the police
[Music]
station well if it isn't our old friend
Chris R we've been looking for a reason
to bust you for
years take him to prison he's in jail
now thanks Johnny you're a favorite
citizen okay okay all right that's
amazing we should go check on Danny all
right let's go let's go check on Danny
you're not my [__]
[Applause]
mother no Danny Danny are you okay Denny
I'm okay are you okay I'm okay what's
okay he's talking taking drugs come on
stop it was a mistake a mistake that he
takes drugs let's go
home come on come on it's
clear what's clear I'm going to call the
police mom stop it was Daddy's mistake
just stop let's go why did they go I
don't understand why are they I don't
why did you do this you know better
right I'm sorry
why I'm
sorry you you know better Denny you
almost got
killed I'm sorry it won't happen again
again I promise Danny you know that
Johnny's like your father and we're your
friends we're going to help
you let's go home take Danny home
great ah let's go to D thanks for
walking me home
[Music]
guys oh all right it's it time time for
baby
practicing oh hi
Johnny I need that carpet I'm going to
call clet and make sure she's got home
okay you should take a shower Johnny you
stay okay all right we took a shower we
shake that that
booty Johnny has a great ass I got to
say it's it's an amazing ass you
remember my name shley Hamilton she
found a new house and needs money for
the down payment I would help her but I
don't have but I have my own problems my
jerk brother Harold oh my God Harold
wants me to give me a share a share of
my house not to mention and I just found
out I definitely have breast
cancer it's so sad could you lend you
could have a whole game just based on
that a whole story could you lend her
the
money that would be an awkward
situation I expected you to be a little
bit more generous and what is this I
hear about you hitting Lisa I did not
hit Lisa I did not I did not hit her
it's not true it's [__] I did not
hit her I did not what are you talking
about Lisa told me you got drunk last
night and hit her the rage is building
up I did not hit her I did
not don't get so worked up go cool off
on the
roof yes
yes I did not hit her it's not true it's
[__] I did not hit her I did not oh
hi Mark oh hey Johnny what's up
I have a problem with Lisa she said that
I hit her what well did you no I it's
not true don't even ask what's new with
you well I just I'm just sitting up here
thinking you
know I got a question for you
yeah you think girls like to cheat like
guys
do what makes you say that you think
girls like to cheat like guys do
what makes you say that I don't have to
worry about that because Alisa is loyal
to
me it's so
sad she's not Loy yeah man you never
know people are very strange these days
what the [__] does that mean what does
that mean people are very strange these
days I used to know a girl she had a
dozen guys one of them found out about
it beat her up so bad she ended up at a
hospital on Guerrero
Street this such a horrible story and he
always goes
[Laughter]
like one of them found out about it beat
her up so bad she ended up in a hospital
on Guerrero
Street also apparently Johnny lives on
Guerrero Street and he was super pissed
about sorry I didn't mean to tell your
address but it was pissed about that
being in there I don't know how it got
in there anyway I'm so happy you I have
you as my best friend it hurts and I
love Lisa so much ah it hurts yeah man
yeah you're very lucky well maybe you
should have a girl Mark yeah yeah maybe
you're right maybe I have one already I
don't know
yet well what happened remember Betty
that's her name Betty yeah yeah we don't
see each other anymore you know she
wasn't any good in bed she was beautiful
but we had too many arguments that's too
bad my Lisa is great when I can get did
oh man I just can't figure women out
sometimes they're just too
smart sometimes they're just flat out
stupid other
times they're just
e it seems to me that you're the
expert I'm the only one who think this
is
funny no definitely not an expert
Johnny what's bothering you mark nothing
man do you do you have some Secrets
forget
it why don't you tell me come on forget
it
dude is it some secret come on I'll talk
to you later well
whatever daddy in his giant forehead
he's so cute look at Denny hey Johnny oh
hi
[Music]
Denny what's wrong with
Mark he's cranky today girl trouble I
guess what's new with you not much still
going to the movie tonight oh sure we
are what movie what kind of movie are we
going to see don't plan it out too
much it may not come out
right all right let's toss the ball
around please please please let me toss
the ball with Danny
yes
yes I got to tell you something oh [__]
I so we got
it I don't know why they did all the
dialogue with these throws shoot Danny
it's about
Lisa oh so Danny first says he loves
Lisa she's beautiful she looks great in
a red dress I think I'm in love with her
so she he says he's in love with her go
on I know she doesn't like me because
sometimes she's mean to me but sometimes
when I'm around her I feel like I want
to kiss her and tell her that I love her
I don't know I'm just confused Danny
don't worry about don't worry about that
Lisa loves you too as a person as a
human being as a
friend you know people don't have to say
it you know people don't have to say
it they can feel it you can love someone
deep inside your heart you're dropping
so much knowledge right now man I feel
inspired to write my own book about
myself inside your heart there is
nothing wrong with it if a l people love
each other the world would be a better
place to
live Lisa is your future wife Danny
don't worry about it you're a part of
our family and we love you very much we
will help you in any time and Lisa loves
you too as a friend you are sort of like
her
son you mean you're not upset with me no
because I trust you and I trust
Lisa what about Elizabeth huh well I
great he loves Elizabeth now he loves
Elizabeth good old good old Elizabeth
when I graduate from college get a good
job I want to marry her and have kids
with her that's the
idea you're right thanks for paying my
tuition you're well welcome Danny and do
keep in mind if you have any
problems talk to me I will help you
awesome thanks Johnny let's go eat huh
come on let's go I'm
starving I love them I love them like
they were my own channel at least Danny
Danny is definitely my son are we
actually going to go and eat at the
coffee shop maybe that would make
[Music]
sense I don't know we can go here as
well probably here
then why is so Street nice electronic
store oh yeah this is a back
alley okay uh all right we're do going
to the coffee shop
[Music]
then apparently he owns this building in
the movie I'm not sure if that's correct
or
not but uh let's talk to them hi Johnny
what can I get for
you we're not getting the cheesecake nah
not the cheesecake I kind of want to
pick
[Music]
okay you're our billionth cheesecake
served I know I could count on you
Denny so Denny how's the cheesecake it's
amazing Johnny you should try some no
thanks too late anyway just ate it all
thanks for paying my cheesecake
Johnny I guess I should be getting
home oh this is too much for me man I
hope you're still watching h honestly
cuz this I'm loving this so much hello
oh [__] it's them they've been talking
now I heard you what's secret it's
between us
women oh Jesus Christ her face did you
get a new dress uh well I bet rude we'll
just talk to you guys later excuse
me Lisa remember what I told you you you
feel it in John's perspective or because
he's so oblivious he doesn't know the
sad truth of the reality what's she
talking about it's girl talk I just told
you that see she's so angry now I never
hit
[Music]
you you shouldn't have any secrets from
me I am your future husband your future
husband you sure about that maybe I'll
change my mind Lisa don't talk like
that what do you mean what do you think
women change their minds all the time
you must be kidding aren't you women
change their minds all the
time you must be kidding aren't you look
I don't want to talk about it I'm going
to go upstairs wash up and go to bed oh
the rage is building up how dare you
talk to me like
that you should tell me
everything I can't talk right
now why Lisa why is that please please
talk to me
please you are part of my life you are
everything I could not go on without you
Lisa you're scaring
me you're lying I never hit you youing
me
apart yes yes why are you so
hysterical do you understand life I love
that line do you do you understand
life do you do you understand life do
you don't worry about it everything will
be don't worry about it everything will
be all right you drive me
crazy good night Johnny don't worry
about don't worry about it I still love
you can not
[Music]
listen it's Saturday oh oh my God it's
the
alley
yes hey Johnny what's going on oh hi
Mike what's new actually Johnny I've got
a little bit of a tragedy it's this guy
I'm acting right now see by the
Expressions on my face I am doing acting
uh-huh me and Michelle we were making
out and uh at your
place now actually he's a bit asleep
during this
[Music]
scene he must be crazy
and uh Lisa and clette sort of uh walked
in on us uh in the middle of uh walked
in on
it that's not the end of the
story go on go on I'm listening go on
I'm definitely
[Music]
listen oh go go on
I'm okay we're going at it and I'm going
to try to get there as fast as possible
and well you you know I get in my pants
and I get my shirt and I get out of
there and then about halfway down the
stairs I realize I'm misplaced I have
forgotten
[Music]
something all my me
underwears so I you know I come back to
get it you know and I pretend that I
need a book you know like I'm looking
for my book and I reach in to put
underwear in my pocket and start slide
out real quick well clette saw it stick
it in my talk she pulls it out and she's
uh showing everybody me
underwears you must be kidding underwear
I get the
picture yeah I don't know what to
do that's
life that's life that's life that's life
that's life that's
life oh hi Danny you guys want to play
some football do this is this how you
play football do you just toss the ball
around or is there anything else
involving in the football
play I got to go see Michelle in a
little bit let make out
whatever H come on come on Mike Let's Do
It come on all right whatever let's go
for it I'm going
out yes yeah sorry you had to see that
I'm not sorry oh
yes all right now we get to throw [__]
I'm so bad at
throwing this is
[Music]
beautiful throw it to me God damn it Go
Johnny Yes amazing catch let's let's see
if I can get your [__] throw down I
don't know why I struggle so much with
the goddamn
[Music]
throw ah got it
there it
[Music]
is be careful hey Denny what's up what's
up Mark oh hi Mark what's going on
man not too much what about you
guys we was just telling you he was just
telling us about the underwear she has
dude
don't underwear what's that that dude
it's uh it's embarrassing man I don't
want to get in underwear man come on
underwear man underwear man come
on Amazing total KO I'm sorry I'm sorry
Johnny underwear man come
on you okay you okay are you all right
are you okay yeah are you sure
uh-huh want to go see a doctor no I'm
good I'm all right I'm fine I'm going to
take him home mark why don't you take
him home and Mike listen if you need
anything anytime call me all right okay
see you guys see you guys he's not my
husband he's in the
staircase no I know my Johnny is part of
our family mom I don't love Johnny
anymore I don't even like
him I had sex with don't listen don't
listen
no you can't be serious you don't
understand who is it I don't want to
talk about it you don't want to talk
about it then why did you bring it up in
the first place good question I don't
know you don't know if you think I'm
tired today wait till you see me
tomorrow coming to the party sure I
suppose
so I will show them how can they say
this about me I don't believe it I show
them I show them I will record
everything record
everything that is that not is that not
what you're supposed to record I guess
we got to go upstairs
first oh here's the phone H oh oh here
is a
cassette where's his tape where's the
cassette
tape what do I do how do I record it
this should be obvious what's
happening how do you record
everything you look so creepy behind
there dude this should be
obvious record everything how do I
record
[Music]
everything doesn't he go up stairs and
get like
[Music]
a it's in a drawer isn't
it I actually don't know what to do here
all right
Tommy I did not cheat I did not uh but I
uh did look up cuz uh of course I'm
stupid there's a the electronic
store that we have to go to
obvious tape recorder on sale
great hi
doggy hey Johnny recorders are on sale
this week they let you record
everything
oh
yes I never know when I may need to
record things thanks Johnny you're my
favorite customer Johnny is such a great
customer Johnny is such a great
everything all right time to record
everything it's not like he just heard
them anyway why would he need to record
them you already proved whatever all
right what it doesn't let's grab this
and put it there I record
everything oh hi Peter oh Peter hi
Johnny I know don't understand women do
you Peter What man does I don't
understand women do you Peter so Peter
is supposed to be a
psychologist and then literally a minute
later he's like don't be a psychologist
with me what man does what's the problem
they never say what they mean and they
always play games Okay um what do you
mean I have a serious problem with Lisa
um I don't think she's faithful to me in
fact I know she isn't Lisa are you sure
yeah I'm sure I overheard a conversation
between Lisa and her mother what should
I do Peter this is Lisa we're talking
about yeah I don't know what to
say what are you
psychologist do you have
some but you're oh yeah but you are
psychologist do you have some advice
it's a complicated situation Johnny I
mean you're my friend and I don't I
don't get between you and Lisa but look
if you want to you should confront her I
can't confront her I want to give her a
second chance after all she's my future
wife you know what they say love is
black you know what they say love is
blind yes
knowledge well you know what you got a
lot of faith in Lisa sometimes life gets
complicated and the unexpected can
happen when it does we just got to deal
with it
did you hear the door
y oh hi Mark oh hey
Johnny hey Peter we're just talking
about women women women man they just
confused
me I have a girl but she's
married I mean she's very attractive
it's just it's driving me
crazy why didn't you mention this before
is there anyone I know n man you don't
know her can night meet her oh Tommy or
Johnny
no h i don't think so it's an awkward
situation you could say that again I
mean she's too old for you for you you
mean she's too old or you think I would
take her away from
me huh no I have my own problems tell me
about your promise Johnny Peter you play
psychologist with us I have my own
problems tell me about your problems
Johnny Peter you always play
psychologist with us Lis is teaching me
about whether we are going to get
married or not and we didn't make love
in a while spend one day spend one day
look you should tell her about your
feelings okay you shouldn't hide them
you two have been together forever you
can work out anything as long as you
talk about it I don't like how he's
playing psychologist with us here I
don't I don't like it not always people
are people sometimes they just can't see
their own faults yeah I'm thinking of
moving to a bigger place man I'm making
some good money what is he doing making
some good money what is he doing what is
his job is the computer business not
that
competitive is he a drug
dealer that would actually make a lot of
sense if he sells weed or something look
you should tell her the truth I mean
you're doing this for the for your girl
right you're right pacher is she do is
she getting a divorce Mark you guys are
too much hey are you running Bay to
Breakers this year oh my God this
[__] part that doesn't add any value
to anything n I'm not doing that this
year chicken Peter you're just a little
chicken chicken Peter you just a little
chicken chip chip chip chip chip
chip who are you calling a chicken I
just don't like all the weirdos there's
too many weirdos there I I don't mind
Mark do you remember the one with the
the big tit the
blonde no how about the one with the
bridal gown with a
sign yeah can you marry me I thought it
would take her up on
it I never ate so much yeah the barbecue
chicken was delicious right so
cool you guys prove my point you're both
weird you guys want to play cards no I
can't I expect Lisa any minute hey come
on man who's the king of the house yeah
you guys got to see what she's like
before you get married speaking of which
how did you meet Lisa you never told us
oh it's a very interesting story oh
that's a very interesting story uh when
I moved to San Francisco with chuk and I
didn't know anyone I hit the YMCA here
with that $2,000 check with I couldn't
cash why not well because I was an out
of state bank anyway I was a [__] sorry
she was so beautiful and I say hi to her
hi and that's how we met so what's the
interesting part well the interesting
part is that on our first date she paid
for
dinner so
interesting oh my God there's a kitchen
I need to make a sandwiches for Mark and
[Music]
Peter what
what
[Music]
okay
cute why am I it's
okay oh okay how about a banana is it
good banana Su
[Music]
sandwich all right one gets a banana
sandwich I'm in America now I can put
other things
inide sorry I didn't know
uh
guess we'll guess we'll put some more
things on this sandwich I don't know
what else to put on it really maybe this
little piece
[Music]
of what am I doing with my life okay are
we done with
this hell yeah that's a Tommy wi so
approved
sandwich there's a sandwich for Mark now
I'll make okay I guess we'll make
another one for Peter for no reason
other
[Music]
than filling the Gap the fact that he
never made any
sandwiches uh so I'm really glad finally
that we are making the sandwiches to
fulfill this movie 100% of what happened
with the sandwiches now we
know I can go to tell I can go tell Mark
and Peter their sandwiches
already Wy Peter Marco they had to run
Denny says hi but I just made them a
snack apparently they weren't that
hungry by the way I stopped by the dress
shop to check in your tux will be ready
tomorrow oh great I'm excited to try it
on let's go to bed I love the soundtrack
so much it's so
beautiful so The Tux Shop oh wait sorry
it's the wrong way why didn't you tell
me how could you do
this tuxedo rental and women fashion
that makes sense hey are we the favorite
customer great news your tux is
ready oh we got it hi
doy you're my favorite customer you need
to try your tux on before you leave oh
okay hell yeah you look good this tux
fic is great great Johnny and thanks for
undressing
in go home am I your favorite customer
yes I am thank
you oh this is going to be the
Meetup everyone's going to come
in is the phone upstairs hi Johnny I saw
you on the street and wanted to say that
Tu looks great oh hi Susan thanks you
look better than A Slice of Cheesecake
oh thank you oh it's the girl from the
shop you do like cheesecake cuz she kept
wanting them to eat
cheesecake yeah thanks a lot oh hi Danny
Danny nice talk you look great you look
really
handsome your wedding picture is going
to look great a
thanks hey Peter come on in bye Peter
you look really good too sit
down why did the yous all going
together yes wow hey guys you like it
yeah Danny's Got a Boner yeah looks
good you look great you look like a baby
face you guys want to play some football
in tux nah you got to be kidding come on
markk let's do it I'm up for it Johnny
ask Peter come on Peter no I don't think
so please nope come on chip chip chip
chip chip chip chip chip chip chip chip
chip chip chip chip chip chip chip
[Music]
okay fine let's go let's play in front
of the electronic
store yeah why did they go there to do
it it or is it supposed to be the same
building doesn't make any
sense just hit
me no it's not it's it's actually um uh
you made a mistake here game
um it's supposed to be outside the house
right
oh yeah because there clearly they went
just somewhere else and there is an
electronic store I'm sorry never mind
I'm wrong catch Johnny oh my God not
this [__]
[__]
yes I can I cannot do
these it works
anyway he's going to fall he's going to
[Music]
fall throw it to me
[__] it always sils me when he
falls go go
deep I always love how he falls in a
different direction of that what he was
running like it was running this way but
he falls this doesn't matter that's it's
a minor it's a minor glitch in The
[Music]
Matrix wait we got to take a shower for
[__]
sake fine I'll take a
shower not a
[Music]
problem I'm feeling a little lightheaded
guys I'm G to go home and laying down
all right P enjoy your
[Music]
nap why do they all have the tox on I
don't all right see you
Denny you want to meet at the coffee
shop tomorrow after work sure Mark that
would be great all right see you very
[Music]
soon I can't wait to have that
cheesecake thanks for coming I'm very
thirsty I'm very busy I'm very thirsty
why do they have a picture of Tommy I'm
customer of the Year again nice oh oh hi
Johnny what can I get for you uh he what
is he get he gets
a
large oh yeah he has
minty man I'm so tired of girls games
what's happened now Mark relationships
never work why waste my time what makes
you say that
it's not that easy Johnny well you
should be happy Mark yeah I know life is
too
[Music]
short oh thank you Susan here it comes
you're welcome how about something like
cheesecake how about something like
cheesecake no real good all
right no not today it's really
good all
right
oh the cheesecake how was work today uh
pretty good we have a new client and the
bank will make a lot of money what
client I cannot tell you it's
confidential oh come on why not no I
can't anyway how's your sex life anyway
how's your what's going on Johnny not
much you good today oh yeah throw it
good throw you was you man much I love
the part where they run cuz you can feel
the chemistry the connection between the
characters it's truly there now where's
the park I actually don't
know I don't think we walked further
than
this the oh yeah we did police
station police here it is Lisa Park
special thanks to Johnny our favorite
Don donor donator hey hey Johnny how's
it going good throw the ball
yes keep throwing the
ball how am I this [__] bad at
throwing the goddamn
ball hell
[Music]
yeah you've got to be kidding
me oh it's going
[Music]
long you have got to be kidding
me
are they going to yog
now catch me come on what the
[__] oh [__] I got to
catch I got to catch
him this is just like the movie guys
just like the
movie come on you you technically caught
him
no
no ah what the hell good run Johnny see
you
[Music]
later ah surprise it's your birthday and
you invited all your friends such there
he is there is a
psychiatrist happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you oh wow happy birthday
dear Johnny all right all thank you
Happy Birthday to
youo thank you thanks hey everybody
let's go outside for some some fresh air
why I love how they did derp face as
well Chris R what are you
[Music]
doing
yes now we know now we know what
happened to the psychiatrist that never
showed up at the party and instead this
other [__] dude showed up hell
yeah hey everybody I have a new
announcement Lisa looks hot tonight yes
everyone compliment Lisa of how hot she
is I got to see if clet will give me me
underwear back to me hey maybe Lisa need
some help downstairs let's go see what's
up Steve needs to keep his stupid
comments in his
pocket
Steve is that the other psychiatrist oh
yeah there it is thank you honey this is
a beautiful party you invited all my
friends good thinking good thinking
you're welcome darl you know how much I
love
you you know it's getting really hot in
here why don't we go back why do we have
to keep going back up and down
and fine fine we're going
up everyone's going up hey buddy I have
an announcement to make we're expecting
when how what why when what Lisa I have
to talk to you you have to got to be
honest with Johnny I agree with that
look I'm going to tell him okay it's
just don't want to ruin his birthday
when is the baby dude there
is what what what are you talking about
I told him that to make it interesting
what do you mean
interesting you [__] we're you life
sucking suckubus we're probably going to
have a baby eventually anyway you're not
going to tell Johnny are you Lisa are
you feeling Lisa are you feeling all
right Lisa are you feeling okay this is
just getting worse and worse I feel like
I'm sitting on an atomic bomb waiting
for it to go off oh that's what they
were saying before me too there's no
simple solution to this
don't worry you guys worry entirely too
much about me Lisa we're not worried
about you we're worried about Johnny you
don't understand the psychological
impact of what you're doing here he does
because he's a psychiatrist you're
hurting yourself you're hurting our
friendship I'm not responsible for
Johnny I'm through with that I'm CH I'm
changing I have the right don't I people
are changing all the time I have to
think about my future what is it to you
this is going to pull us all down it's
going to shake us up our group of
friends it's going to destroy our
friendship Lisa I don't think Mark
really loves you I don't want to talk
about it Lisa you're going to have to
face it I for one I'm going to have a
hard time forgiving you if you don't hey
everybody let's go inside and eat some
cake it's going down I'm sorry I
couldn't lend your friend money clet
that's all right darling I will explain
to Shirley that it's an awkward
situation whoa whoa just stop asking me
stupid questions who the hell do you
think you are just shut up what what are
you doing what are you doing what's
going on
here you don't really know do you maybe
I maybe I know more than I think
you yes a [__] all right what do you
want from me
huh stop it all right all right okay Fox
everything's fine fighting so I'm sorry
Mark I'm sorry M yeah me too Lee sec can
you clean up
here why why does she have to clean up
he's going to the kitchen I need to cool
up before I go back out there cool up so
basically they show the same scene twice
like for some reason he just goes away
same thing I have to cool
off how do I cool off ah that feels nice
I'm ready to go back in good call good
call and they're just back again like
what are you doing none of your business
what what happened what are you doing
none of your business well he was
calling off you're my future wife Lisa
what are you doing Lisa leave her alone
man she doesn't want to talk to you this
since when do you give her ORD since
Lisa changed her mind about you ha wake
up man what planet are you on I think
you should leave right now Mark don't
spoil it we were just having fun don't
worry about it man don't touch me don't
touch me don't touch me [__] get
out stop it you two are acting like
children you're going to ruin the party
son of a [__] you keep your girl
satisfied she wouldn't come to me get
out of my house I kill you I break every
bone in your
body
oh yes it's going down
hell yeah uh throw
bottle
yes take that you piece of
[Music]
[__] a [__] it does more damage now all
right I'll ta
to
[__] I must win this for
Lisa
chip chip chip chip chip
[Music]
chip
[__] what happens if I run what happens
if I
run run Tommy run at least I will never
love you if you quit for [__] sake
okay
[Music]
then well I'm clearly going to
die chip chip chip chip chip
[Music]
chip
why it's too
hard it's a lot harder than it looks
okay calm
[Music]
down there it
is damn
it stop it I'll kill you bastard you can
kill me if you tried you betray me
you're that good you're just a
chicken get
him it's the battle of the
centuries it's over it's over it's not
over everybody betray me I'm fed up with
this
world I clean up oh he crying
I clean up the kitchen sweetheart so you
don't have to worry about that he still
won't come out of the bathroom
sweetheart he's upset now Johnny is a
sensible man he will come out you will
discuss this everything is going to be
okay I just think I should be alone with
him right now I understand sweetheart
I'm going to go home now bye-bye you
call me if you need me I will thanks
Mom you can come out now Johnny she's
gone in a few minutes [__] you can come
out now Johnny she's gone
in a few minutes [__] I love that line
I love that line it's so beautiful who
are you calling a [__] you and your
stupid mother you and your stupid
mother hi Mark I need to talk to you
don't worry about Johnny he's just being
a big baby you know I love you very much
but he's recording I love you I know
he's not worth it why don't I come up
there and be with you you got it I'm on
my way bye
who were you talking to nobody we'll see
about that cuz he was
recording good thing I've been recording
everything
yes cuz everyone knows cassette players
they record forever they got so much
storage
yes play that [__]
[Music]
John hello
hi Mark I need to talk to you what's
going
on don't worry about Johnny he's just
being a big baby hi Mark I need to talk
to you and and the the whole
conversation is completely different as
well don't worry about Johnny's just
being a big baby you know how much I
love you you're the the sparkle in my
life I can't live without you when did
she say that I love you you little [__]
how could you do this to me how could
you do this to me I give you seven years
of my life and you betray me let's see
what else we have on this tape no stop
you little prick I put up with you for
7even
years you think you're an angel you're
just like everybody I treat you like a
princess and you stab me in the back I
love you I do anything for you just to
please you and now you betray me how
could you love him how could you love
him how could you love him why didn't
you get this crepe I don't like him
anymore I I know he's not worth it why
don't I come up there and be with you
sure baby come up I want your body you
got it everybody betray me I don't have
a friend in the world what about Denny
what about
psychiatrist what about your employ I'm
I'm leaving you
Johnny get out get out get out of my
life get out get out get out of my
life yes
[Music]
yes why Lisa
why the r is
[Music]
building he's going to go Citizen
Kane yes smash the fake fruit the TV is
out the
door break the glasses screw the whole
world world not the sp
sp give we go in the kitchen we're
stuck Tommy why
zor not the bananas not what are you
doing let's go upstairs he doesn't go in
the
[Music]
kitchen that's right lamp that's right
uh
thing stupid
everything I love how he randomly has a
rock as well who has a [__] rock in
their house and he just throws it at the
window ah shame they didn't do
that uh all right we have the gun
no no it's too sad it's too
[Music]
sad why why is this happening to me
why it's
over God please forgive
me
[Music]
they they also use Kool-Aid to do the
blood which I really appreciate it oh
no wake up Johnny come on is he dead my
God Mark is he dead yes he's dead oh my
God I lost him but I still have you
right you don't have me you'll never
have me you killed him Mark we're free
to be together love you I love you [__]
you killed him you're the cause of all
of this I don't love you get out of my
life you [__] what's happening Danny no
don't look Danny don't look Johnny's
dead wake up Johnny please it's not
right it's not right he's in he's in a
better place leave
us both of you L as far as I'm concerned
you can drop off the Earth and that's a
promise just leave both of you leave him
all right let him be with
him why Johnny why Johnny why why who's
going to pay his
tuition yes
yes he's going he's in higher
entity his soul will go to
[Music]
heaven
is that a spoon it's a
spoon yes so tell me Janny what is
happening right now how was your time on
Earth what the [__] it was enchanting
for a moment but I've had I always had
my suspicion that you were an alien but
uh I've had enough of that world and
Lisa the situation with Lisa was
unfortunate sadly we may never
understand life do you understand you
hands the handsome one mark My best
friend he questioned what planet you
were from yes that is when I knew my
time was coming to an end as All Things
Must so tell me Johnny how many spoons
did you
find looks like you have wait you can
collect the spoons a come on I missed
that unfortunately that would be enough
to activate the machine no need to Suk
number 86 this is a Time of Celebration
indeed it
is
hey oh the
room inspired by Tommy wi buy it on DVD
go ahead and buy it I'll leave a link to
it in in the description Tom P ful made
it
sorry that's
aome Chris what the hell I know who
these people
are
that's amazing what an amazing game
honestly that was so well made it was
such a blast I really hope it was fun
maybe even Oh okay that's cool maybe if
you haven't even seen the movie I hope
that was entertaining regardless it's
such a fun game oh my God the
Pug oh that was beautiful it did change
my life
forever that was amazing I'm speechless
that was amazing
thank you for watching so much leave a
like if you enjoyed I really appreciate
it uh check out the game play it see if
you can find all the spoons I'll leave a
link to the movie and the game and uh
have a great one this is this is so fun
stay awesome br